you have one of the most interesting
Instagram accounts I've followed
probably in the last year and everybody
needs to go and follow at the Tin Men on
Instagram I absolutely love it these
infographic Carousel slides that you've
been doing I think are they're
phenomenal they're very well researched
I think you're an incredibly balanced
voice in this space so what's the reason
that you personally decided to get
interested in the topic of talking about
men and men's issues
um well I work in the creative industry
I create content for a living I've been
doing it I've specifically been filmed
for about 13 years now
um I've always found it very interesting
to sort of communicate data to audiences
um I also engage heavily in sort of
progressive left-leaning sort of
political spaces and as those two parts
of my life were developing I sort of
noticed an unwillingness from
Progressive left spaces to engage in
good faith with an area which I was
always passionate about which is men and
boys advocacy and
to be honest like I was quite naive when
I started the journey I didn't know a
huge amount about anything I spoke about
so there's a lot of reading and I
remember just being absolutely shocked
at the data some of the information I
was reading I just could not believe it
and I I felt like as a creative with a
lot of experience I was like I've been
dealt a winning hand here there was so
much interesting information so many
undeniable facts about men and boys I
saw an area of advocacy men and boys
advocacy men's right advocacy especially
is experiencing what I think is a
massive brand identity crisis it's like
very loud very aggressive it's very sort
of in your face and I thought if I can
just change the way we present this
information which is compelling and I'm
sure we'll get into if I can just change
the way we present it through my own
experience I think I can change their
minds and some some Minds having changed
some Minds have been entrenched but
I just had to do it I just thought I had
to do it I I just didn't see in my
reality what I was being told about what
it is to be a man and the facts didn't
seem to add up and I was like I just
need to try and present these things to
be honest it wasn't even really supposed
to be a public Channel like I was
engaging so much in these discussions
um we have a lot of feminists and I just
wanted a space on my phone quite
literally to be able to reference
information about like suicide domestic
violence uh violent crime homelessness
drug addiction and I just wanted
something to be under the table and I
mean like what literally into the table
so I could switch it's like swipe
through and following my own beliefs
like engage in this discussion
um
with that due diligence and then people
would have started to follow and then
some of the wrong people start to follow
and give me some
some [__] which is fine and then it grew
and it grew and it grew and then I spent
a bit more time pers like personalizing
the content to make it a little bit more
entertaining a bit more attractive in
the way that you described so kindly
and then I'm here now I'm here so you
are somebody that is from the left very
much so I've seen your political Compass
yeah and yet you're pro-men what what is
first off why is it such a rare position
and secondly what's unique about what
you've learned being in those spaces
holding those beliefs and yet talking
about the issues of boys and men I mean
even saying pro-men is sort of it makes
you wince doesn't it it's like oh my God
that's unpopular I mean obviously I'm
Pro all human beings including women of
course I speak I do speak actively about
human as well yeah this is like this is
something I've always found frustrating
is that whenever we have these
discussions it always starts with some
sort of like prospective apology where
we sort of get down on these and we
plead and we have to like someone know
to talk to the other day said you have
to kiss the ring
and you always have to kiss them you
always have to acknowledge women and
girls you can't just talk about men and
boys I know I know you've spoken to
Richard Reeves he does this quite often
he starts everything by saying now I'm
going to speak about poison men that
doesn't mean I don't care about women
and girls uh and if anything talk about
men and boys is of benefit to women and
girls and I find by doing that you you
sort of undermine your own point before
you even begun and I genuinely believe
men and boys deserve a conversation in
their own right
not for benefit women and girls although
that is a benefit an indirect benefit
but primarily this is about men and boys
uh doesn't that we have to do it now
that doesn't mean I don't care about
women and girls and I'm not going to say
that again for the rest of podcast
because I don't think I need to
continually have to prove myself but um
as for your question
I just think
I do think they're right has done a
better job of talking about men and boys
certainly not perfect but the
progressive left spaces just seem very
intent on blaming women boys for their
own problems so if men have poor health
outcomes it's because men aren't going
to uh the doctors enough if men have
mental health problems it's not speaking
enough if a man gets assaulted on the
street we ask who did it and like we
don't actually engage with these
discussions in that good faith and it's
always an accusatory finger and then we
obviously we get to the concepts of
toxic masculinity and patriarchy which
in my opinion again speaking as someone
who works as a for a living writing copy
I feel like there's words
um they just place the blame back on men
shoulders and they divide people and I
was just like I think I could do a
better job I think I can do a better job
I think I can bring the progressive
topics
into my account because I the the
frustrating thing is so many of the
issues I talk about are I would say
left-wing issues if you if we're going
to classify left wing as social equality
if you talk about homelessness everyone
wants and homelessness which is great
but 80 of homeless people are are men 90
of homeless deafs are men so really if
you send for homelessness you sort of
indirectly stand for men too right we a
lot of people like hate War like I want
war ended but then
99 of war deaths are men
um and there's so many issues that men
that people care about including like
BLM for example that are that are men's
issues men and boys issues are sort of
re-categorized as something else so like
BLM for example is certainly a racial
issue but I never really thought mention
at all that like 95 96 of Americans
killed by police are men and if you were
to line up like um all of the black
Americans killed in 2020 at the year of
George Floyd 99 of it was black
Americans are black men more more in
fact and it's a great database I think
it's the Washington Post a fatal Force
where they basically have every single
American killed by police and he can
search by race and it's like literally
244 black men killed in 2020 two women
and I I've I never saw it brought up
personally that's the way I've disagreed
with a lot of people in my community but
I never saw it mentioned as a racial and
a gender issue and really if If you deny
police brutality as they um uh a men
men's issue I feel like that's that's
even worse than denying as a black issue
like it is both but it's way more men
proportionally than it is black so when
we're talking about what is Right such a
good point dude right so well
the conversation around
um look at the proportion how many white
people were killed by police versus how
many black people were killed by police
and there may be an imbalance and there
may be a required redress Beyond simply
the the sort of situational
um environments that different groups
inhabit but the real thing would be look
at the
99.45 of people who were male that were
killed by police compared with the ones
that were female yeah so like I think a
number's something like black Americans
when you normalize to a population uh
about 3.5 times more likely to be killed
by police than white Americans which is
a disparity that's worth discussing but
men are 20 times more likely to be
killed by a woman and then when you tell
people that you put them in a very
difficult pace of cognitive dissonance
because they start reaching for or men
are more violent which is why they
killed by police and that certainly
would explain some of the disparity but
then are you going to apply that to the
racial disparity as well and I was like
good luck with that one good luck with
that one I think to be honest it gets
even worse because I feel like not only
do the left neglects that part of the
problem but I'd say the left
actively encourage encourage it I'd say
the left create the very problem they're
trying to solve in personality because a
lot of a lot of these left Progressive
spaces actively participate in a very
dehumanizing fear-mongering around men
that men are dangerous across the street
watch out keep your distance like men
are men are terrifying men are dick men
are violent and I'm like that is
actually feeding into the the divisive
um fear-mongering rhetoric you're sort
of creating a cultural fear around men
and I'm like who's going to pay the
biggest price for that and the answer is
black men like because when police start
fearing um black men that's when black
men get shot and I'm like are the left
creating the very problem they claim to
want to end by explicitly fear-mongering
around men and like I mean that's that's
a controversial question to start with
but
a good one nonetheless I think so what
what do you find when you bring these
sorts of positions up with the
left-leaning friends that you will have
what's the kind of
presumably your left-leaning credentials
must get questioned at some point yeah
you're evidently not from the left you
must be confused despite the fact that
being left or being right is
fundamentally a social issue right it's
to do the problems of class and
economics yeah it's not to do with are
you pro-men like even the the
conversation around being pro-life or
pro-gun neither of those things should
really factor into whether you are or
whether you aren't it's just a
predisposition that's grouped certain
people with a particular Suite of
beliefs into different cohorts so what
what happens you're sat at the pub with
your left-leaning friends some of whom
have got blue hair and you bring up this
conversation around men yeah yes what
happens I lose I I've lost friends I've
lost friends I've lost like people that
acquaintances of mine like family
members like quite literally stand up
and walk out the room like people that I
thought were important to me and cared
about things that were important to me
and that's fine like I know I mean
putting into a case in point I have a
friend
um a male friend who lost uh one of his
old flatmates to Suicide who was a man
and he he sent Round The Virtuous text
message to all his guy friends asking
him to talk and it's good to speak and
share if you want to reach out let me
know which is like very worthwhile and I
think that all men should do that but
then I remember a week later I posted
some information on sexual violence
against men and how it's in the reported
in America and it was a significant
number of male rape victims and then the
next time I saw him he pulled me aside
and that was basically castigated me and
called me tone deaf for saying that and
I was just like mate do you realize that
a boy who has been sexually abused in
adolescence when he grows up is 10 times
more likely to attempt suicide like
sexual violence and suicide are
inextricably linked that they're a
massive part of one another and so how
could he one week say
um male suicide is a big problem let's
talk about it and then the following we
call me tone deaf when I talk about one
of the biggest causes of of suicide and
I mean we talk about that a lot but one
of the biggest one of the biggest things
I've learned is like if you want to talk
about male suicide we need to go a lot
deeper than we've currently gone which
is just surface level men can talk men
can cry which is again a very valid
point and I I would like to use use this
opportunity to encourage mentor talk
about their problems but if you think
suicide starts and stops there you're
wrong it's it's not seen primarily as a
mental health crisis but a societal
issue like it's a really great paper
I'm going on a tangent now but a really
great report that said male suicide is
not a mental health issue primarily it
even described it as a a rational
decision and a solution-based outcome
when men simply cannot deal with the
problems around them and a lot of the
men who attempted suicide didn't even
consider consider that they had a mental
health problems they didn't consider
themselves as mentoring well they're
like I'm not mentally and well I'm in
debt I've lost my job I'm losing my
children in child custody courts I'm I'm
a victim of domestic violence like
that's another another really difficult
a bit of hypocrisy from the left where
if you look at male victims of domestic
violence of which there are currently 3
million in the UK
um 11 of those men will attempt suicide
so it's frustrating when you talk to
Advocates who are against male suicide
and that's an important issue to them
but then they'll refuse to talk about
domestic violence against men I meant I
mentioned child custody and um Martin
Sieger who is an excellent psychologist
he he's linked 20 of the suicides in the
UK to child custody battles family
courts relationship breakdown and like
the family court system in the UK is one
of the most heartbreaking
um institutions you will ever see and
that for a father to lose his child in a
corrupt Family Court causes so much pain
and a lot of those men they're not
mentoring well they've just lost their
child and um if you're a male suicide
I'll Advocate male suicide and you're
not talking about child custody
joblessness Melbourne domestic violence
I will question
how effective you're being and if
anything there are people that I
genuinely feel like are not talking
about the real shoes they're just trying
to sell things like if anything's sort
of exploiting the issue by not wanting
to get their hands dirty by you know
playing in the mud like I am I'm the one
yeah they want to talk about the very
virtue
virtuous and applauded elements of
communicating with men and boys which is
you need to learn to open up you need to
get rid of your man box of expectations
around what it means to be a man but
when you talk about what are the
precursors to this which are a little
bit more politically unpopular things
like male rape things like men who are
being mistreated through Family Court
men who have lost things in marriages
and divorce court and stuff like that
that is a much more contested area I
mean this is this is a you know the
absolute rubber meeting the road
situation of every social topic
if you hold a belief and say that you're
standing up for a maligned group and yet
that belief is applauded by most people
that's not really making any sort of a
sacrifice like you somebody who is from
the left talking about something that
the left absolutely hates which is men's
problems and not only that talking about
men's problems in a domain which is
almost exclusively dominated by women
that's somebody as far as I can see that
is paying the price you mentioned before
and this is something I've seen pop up
on YouTube quite a lot about uh Family
Court child custody uh separations and
stuff like that this is an area that I
have done zero Research into I know I
know absolutely nothing so given that
you are coming at it from uh
evidence-based research-backed lens what
what don't people know about how family
court and and divorces and separations
and stuff works for men I would say the
fact that you don't you don't know and I
would say I don't know a huge man about
either but the fact that we don't know
is an interesting outcome in and of
itself flight we don't know because
we're not allowed to know our family
Court's a secret the secret family court
so you're not allowed to press you're
not allowed public there's very little
oversight like
parents given up children and then a
father comes out on his own heartbroken
we don't know what's going in going on
there I mean I would be very I'd be
reluctant to talk too much about it but
I know it's something I'm learning about
and every time I speak to a dad who's
fighting for his child that is probably
the most heartbreaking story I'll hear
like I don't when we talk about I feel
like when we talk about politics so much
of it's descended into things like women
not having Pockets or uh the sound of my
Alexa being a woman's voice and those
are sort of issues that are important
but you need to put those down on the
ladder a little bit when a man is losing
his child I'll just ask any parent like
what's the one thing you don't want to
lose and I'd say like nine times out ten
I'll say my child and when you consider
how many men are losing their child in a
system that is corrupt
I sure that's a bigger issue than it we
then we pretend is and not just family
courts but men are discriminated against
in many areas of Criminal Court like I
know there's been some interesting
research by uh Professor Sandra star and
she found that women are twice as like
to avoid prison for the same crime
um and if they are sentenced men will
get 63 longer sentence that's in America
but again for the same crime same
criminal history in in the UK like the
ministry of Justice came out of a report
and I think it said men are 88 more
likely to be sentenced to prison under
similar criminal circumstances and um
very little said and done that's the
main industry of Justice's own report
and a similar similar phenomenon as I
said earlier where there is a sentencing
bias against black Americans 10 is found
so if you're black in America you'll get
10 longer men get 63 longer and if
you're a black man it's 63 plus 10 so
you've got the compounding of the
problem itself uh and you see that
everywhere same obviously BLM we talked
about men are an at-risk group black men
are and even higher risk group and I
think that intersectional approach is a
really interesting and valuable lens
that we should be using isn't that
fascinating so if you if you bring the
word up intersectionality it triggers it
triggers the the the base of the
amygdala goes right on a lot of people
because what they've been taught about
to do with intersectionality is that
this is a justification for somebody
who's got a gluten intolerance and is
Left-Handed to be able to claim some
sort of a victim code whereas what
you're saying here is that not using the
lens of intersectionality allows us to
ignore the problems of poison men and
actually means that a more uh
politically popular
way of segmenting out different cohorts
that are having problems is much easier
to do if you ignore the problems of boys
and men well I mean you see the biggest
so the biggest victims of the problems I
talk about are are minority men we've
talked about black men another good
example is gay men
um obviously we talk a lot about
historical sort of criminalization of
gay people but very few talk about the
fact that it was almost always gay men
in particular who are criminalized so in
the UK it's illegal to be gay and it was
but it was actually legal to be a gay
man like being a lesbian was certainly
not tolerated by any means but you
weren't castrated you weren't sentenced
three years hard labor the same with the
Nazi party when they were sending gay
gay people to um
concentration camps but they weren't gay
people they were all gay men and again
lesbianism was not condoned but it
weren't rounded up and executed tens of
thousands and like I've seen like
popular
instagramers on um talk about what
happened to gay people
um in the Nazi party and you look at the
photos and he's like look at they're all
men like why are you so afraid to say
gay men like that's an important like
the
the intersection of masculinity and
homosexuality is a really really
important point to make and we are
losing that perspective by indulging in
this sort of political correctness I'm
not wanting to talk about men I've never
I've never thought about this lens
before I've never thought about the
other side of intersectionality that you
know you use it from this lens that
allows you to erroneously fold in
unnecessary characteristics in order to
maximize the way that a group is is
being claimed to be maligned it's not
just that you're black but it's that
you're black and you've got a club or
something yeah but when you do it on the
other side it allows you to hide what
may be one of the biggest determining
factors for this and this is almost
exclusively I would guess a problem over
the left so this is a problem that is
mostly present in and mostly driven by
people from the left which who are
ostensibly the group of uh tolerance and
inclusion and trying to raise up
maligned groups but because of this
blind spot toward the problems of boys
and men
it's actually it's it the intersection
or not using an intersectional uh lens
is a disadvantage yeah I I genuinely
feel like some of the issues I discuss
of a new
New Perspectives that are you may not
have to agree with it but they're
certainly worth discussing at the very
least like combining what we talked
about in terms of men being seen as
inherently guilty not just by Society
but by quite literally the criminal
court so like I said 63 longer sentences
for men if you if you apply this sort of
inherent guilt that Society seems to see
men as and you apply that to being gay
that I think explains why we see women
as sort of innocently gay you know it's
a phase I'll get through it don't worry
about it it's fine she's just
experimenting it's an all innocent fun
but men are men are guilty of being gay
because they're applying that that
inherent guilt onto gay men and get they
are quite literally guilty of being gay
there's an Abomination as it's called in
the Bible and and like I said
criminalized in the most literally
possible I had a conversation that I was
doing in in Qatar probably about two or
three months ago now me and you were
chatting beforehand because I wanted to
make sure that I was absolutely on the
nose of this conversation I was having
and you sent me something uh and I've
built this out
um for a project that I'm working on at
the moment I actually wanted to read to
you about today's version of what you
sent me a few months ago okay a common
question is why don't men just do better
surely they can try harder in school
employment and health well no other
group is told when they suffer with
reduced performance or accolades in the
real world that they should just pull
themselves up by their bootstraps we
don't tell any other group to talk about
their problems instead we spend billions
in taxpayer money and private charity to
set up committees departments campaigns
and funds to solve the problem in simple
terms if a woman has a problem we ask
what can we do to fix Society if a man
has a problem we ask what can men do to
fix themselves it's a blatant double
standard and people who are unwilling to
admit any structural disadvantages faced
by men are standing in the way of us
solving the problems that are hurting
men and also the potential Partners who
they may no longer be viable for what's
the point in asking men to talk if we
are unwilling to listen or even
acknowledge the societal issues that
they're talking about the problems are
not in men's heads but out there in
society and we should not Gaslight men
into thinking they can solve these
problems by just trying harder or being
less toxically masculine if the
patriarchy is so powerful why aren't men
flourishing more
I mean that's an excellent rewording of
what I am I said I'm happy to take
credit for it and I hope it went down
well
um I mean can I respond with a quote of
my own absolutely like going back to
suicide is a really interesting vessel
to talk about this this is said appg if
boys and men is a new organization
that's launched in the UK it's all party
parliamentary group so it's different
members of different political parties
coming together to discussion issue
there's one on everything now there's
one on boys and men they did an
absolutely amazing report on male
suicide and this is what they found uh
sort of what I said earlier
um the appg heard that the focus has
been on viewing suicide primarily as a
mental health problem when in reality it
is largely the outcome of a range of
external issues or personal stresses
that take many men down on the path to
Suicide suicide is a symptom or outcome
of a buildup of stresses suicide is a
choice made by men when these stresses
reach a critical level and the stress
bucket overflows it is not the result of
either a single cause or men not talking
these stresses range from a combination
and culmination of issues such as
relationship breakdown work culture
employment Financial worries and the why
and a more widen impacted by social
isolation loss of belonging the lack of
male friendly services and the lack of
empathy towards men we heard evidence
that many men view suicide as a rational
decision and a solution-based outcome
based on their failure to fix these
stresses they often do not conceptualize
their problems as being mental health
problems so I mean I'll read those
issues out again and you tell me Chris
which of these could be solved through
tears relationship breakdown work
culture employment Financial worries
like being in debt isn't solved by
crying I mean I'm sure talk about it
just talk about it yeah yeah bank will
accept that and he will be out of your
own right yeah yeah can you talk about
this for a moment and don't get me wrong
like talking is a way of dealing of the
problem but I don't know how much it
solves the problem it certainly doesn't
solve it in its complexity I I work a
lot of a male suicide researcher called
Susie
and together we've done some very large
cities together we did one of the
biggest studies into most suicide ever
and she has more experience talking to
suicidal men than I think anyone you
could ever meet and what she told to me
on my podcast was that she was like the
more I talk to these men and listen to
the life they're living the more I'm
like [__] I'm not surprised you want to
kill yourself like it sounds awful like
you don't have a mental health problem
we need to stop pathologizing male
suicide and masculinity and actually
listen to what these men are saying like
it's um no appointment talking if we're
not willing to listen and the three
words I I try to bring in are
um
listen ask and act
like what's the point talking so you've
got to listen you've got to act and
you've got to ask and there's no point
there really is a limited
utility to men talking if Society is not
willing to listen or if we're willing to
we tell people what they can and can't
talk about I get told what I kind of
can't talk about on my own page people
come into my page and they're like you
can't say that you can't say that don't
say it this way and I'm like I'll say
what I want
strange how you say Ben can talk but not
about these things and it's like well
it's not really talking if you can't
talk about the things I want to do I
love that I love that insight you're not
saying the right things yeah we want you
to open up but we don't need to open up
in that way we don't need to open up in
a politically uh uncomfortable way do
you see John Barry's sense of male
psychology did you see his new study uh
I still always podcast to you uh oh so
this is a new one this is John uh DM me
this a couple of days ago my latest
research has just been published it
assessed the views of over 4 000 men in
the UK and found that thinking
masculinity is bad for your behavior is
linked to having worse mental well-being
around 85 percent of respondents thought
that the term toxic masculinity is
insulting and probably harmful to boys
yeah yeah the funny thing is I put that
into a post not long ago where I talked
about the indoctrination of boys we talk
a lot about how Andrew Tate is
indoctrinated boys and in a lot of ways
he has I don't support Andrew Tate in
the least but we haven't also talked
about how there are organizations that
are going into schools right now to
indoctrinate boys educate them just like
Andrew Tate but to educate that them
then that they are violent like rapists
in Waiting
um and that that John Barry research
you're talking about I put that in I it
was like a percentage
of boys I've been introduced to the
concept of men being bad for society and
the percentage of boys being told about
toxic masculinity at like 10 years old
and it was really really high and the
reason why I don't know the actual stats
is because that slide was actually
deleted by Instagram somehow that's why
I got that slide got reported and
deleted and I was like there's nothing
wrong about style so it's a really great
example of like
Associated story you might have seen I
put a reel up maybe a month ago uh
talking about the fact that I'd once
recorded a podcast with Andrew Tate but
never released it and I was talking
about the fact that um I'd had the
opportunity to I recorded it maybe three
years ago when he was relatively small
and then I could have re-released it or
I could have released the first time at
the height of his Fame it would have got
millions of plays uh everybody in the
comments a couple of couple of things
first off everybody in the comments was
saying um this is you your morality
standing on the shoulders of of sort of
a high horse here
um like I didn't need to know about the
fact that you consider yourself virtuous
well if I had released it three years
after a very bombastic guy was talking
in the middle of a global pandemic I
would have also been accused of hang on
mate you've stitched him up he didn't
believe this anymore and it would have
been harsh on Andrew I did most of the
reason that I didn't release that a
couple of years later is it's a [__]
thing to do to someone who was making
claims when there was a lot of unknowns
and now there are knowns and you can
prove you can prove false a lot of the
claims that he was making like it's just
a bad thing to do I don't care who he is
but what you think about him you don't
Stitch somebody up with a three-year-old
video anyway that was the first thing
second thing
Instagram took that down Instagram
deleted it and it had
two seconds of him saying hello good to
be here that was it he featured in the
video so that is how tight they are on a
number of uh topics especially around
boys and men so the thing that I've got
in my head you know we've got this
individual elements here whether it be
suicidality homelessness education
relationship breakdown
looking at a bit of a more macro level
why do you think people get angry if you
start to discuss the basic truth that
boys and men face disadvantages
have you ever like had it where
you you you spend a whole day out in
town you're walking around meeting
friends
uh you know go on a date or go for
dinner and you get home and you've had
like food stuck between your teeth like
all day and it's like embarrassing that
is what I think is going on to the left
where they've badged themselves quite
literally bought the T-shirt about their
political ideas they badge themselves
and made their political beliefs a
fundamental part of who they are some
people's jobs are quite literally
dependent on certain political
philosophies and theories being true and
people will fight to the deaf to defend
them they'll look in the mirror and be
like oh oh no and they'll get angry at
everyone else not telling them and um I
feel like to overcome that identity
crisis where your community your friends
your job your lifestyle is all built
around a certain set of ideas if
something comes along that challenges
ideas it's a very difficult thing to
change it's like changing your skin you
can't really do it so which is why I try
not to identify with any political
movement neither MRI or feminism I try
to identify as George and George is a
constantly shifting selection of ideas
that I'm I'm able to bring in take out
as and when I choose I'm not I'm not
sort of confined to my Community I know
there's a
I can't name who I can't remember who
said it but he was saying how
he's a psychologist and he talked about
how
um opinions don't necessarily exist in
someone's skull they exist in a
community it's like a shared belief that
Community has it's not like in someone's
mind so to change someone's mind you
either have to disassociate yourself in
that community and lose friends family
in a way that I described earlier or you
have to change the mind of the entire
Community that's how you change
someone's mind and they're both
extremely hard things to do especially
when you're talking about very important
issues like Domestic and Sexual Violence
where sadly
huge amount of men and women have
personal experiences of that and I
generally I genuinely try to understand
like when people
hate men I try to
understand what has happened to that
person for them to hate men so much when
I the same same principle applies to
look at Violent Men I don't just see
them as an end product of violence I
also I try to look into what have they
experienced so they've become this way I
truly believe that the vast majority of
people are not born bad they've become
bad from their experiences and their
environment so I tried to ask challenge
people to ask themselves what sort of
Journey has that man been on and in the
same way the angry the angry people I
get in my comments and DMs I try to ask
like what have you experienced at the
hands of men
that has made you hate them so much and
I I try to apologize I'm sorry whatever
happened to you happened and I hope you
give a second chance but do you think
that most people who do hold those
beliefs have had first-hand personal
experience of being mistreated by men or
do you think that they see a culture
online that praises and raises up people
who push back against men as far as I
can see it's way more that mimetic I am
holding a belief that is currently
politically popular to hold which is to
I'm gonna stand up for the for the
dispossessed groups and I will ignore
information that suggests that a group
which isn't commonly seen as being
dispossessed actually might be therefore
men bad women good white bad black good
immigrant like good just think that's
not easy yeah we just if I had a
catchphrase it would be treat the issue
not the gender
like just look at the issue and if that
issue impacts 80 of women then 80 of the
benefits will go to women but we need to
look at the issue and like not see just
genders like if you look at domestic
violence like even in the most
conservative estimates one in three
victims is a man and yet there was
there's virtually nowhere for
um men to go so one in three victims at
one percent of refugees for men and like
that is not acceptable if I were to say
there was a group of survivors
who make up one in three victims and
they are systematically shut out of
refuges
people would lose their mind I tried
that all the time I'm like
um if you look at homeless people 90 of
deaths are of one type of group and
people get outraged upset and then you
reveal it's men and then again they're
they're confronted the same sense of
dissonance but um
I don't know it's just a lot it's just a
lot to overcome for some people and I
just don't think people are willing to
put any effort like um
too much part of their life
and uh it's a shame it seems to me I I
learned this originally from Destiny but
I know that you kind of hold a similar
belief here which is that one of the
reasons that the right has dominated the
conversation with men so much is because
it's largely been evacuated by the land
that you don't get to tell men that they
are a problem or have a problem or need
to do better and not hold up
any potential role models for them to
step into you have to provide a positive
inspirational aspirational view for what
men could become and that has almost
exclusively been dominated by the right
and you know for every single person
every single person I don't care who you
are that says I have a problem with
Andrew Tate I have a problem with Jordan
Peterson okay
who do you suggest instead and I asked
the guy who you
um helped me prep for that debate that I
did in Qatar he I came out and they
played this video that was like a bunch
of
individuals famous individuals that
might be accused of being toxically
masculine in one form or another the
first one was Milo yiannopoulos I was
like look if you've brought me here to
defend [__] Milo yiannopoulos I'm on
the wrong show yeah Jordan Peterson Joe
Rogan the usual David Goggins the usual
crowd
and I was like okay um I understand my
interlocutor as I understand that you
have a problem with the people that have
just been held up as potential role
models for men please tell me who you'd
suggest instead and it took 10 minutes
in front of sorry 10 seconds in front of
the live audience of silence for him to
say my brother-in-law and I was like how
about somebody that we all know
it was I didn't mean to be mean but I
think it was a really important moment
that showed if you are from the left it
is really hard to find a positive image
for what men could and should be it's
just it goes back to what you said
before if women have a problem we say
what can we do to fix Society if men
have a problem we say what should men do
to fix themselves yeah yeah yeah you
know yeah quoting all my work now thank
you um
yeah I feel like I would say a better
example is like an example of a
masculine man like there's often an
example there's often certain Role
Models by left of men but I'd say they
don't I wouldn't say they're
traditionally masculine in in the way
they present themselves the strange
thing is that the the things that define
masculinity we do celebrate them but in
women
so when a woman is like confident and
loud and in your face and they go get
her in a boss and you know
we love that and quite rightly so but if
you if you say oh yeah man confident to
go get in fierce in a fighter it's like
oh no we don't we don't like that toxic
toxic toxic and I I it's a shame because
we we just not don't seem to be
benefactors of the lessons of History
because this isn't the first time we've
pathologized agenda like I I part of me
thinks that toxic masculinity is just a
modern equivalent of female hysteria
where we take female distress and we
pathologize it as something to be
treated something that's wrong inside of
them and we subject them to this this
this crazy sort of um experiments to to
fix the problem and we're doing the same
now we see masculinity as a problem to
be fixed and we're subjecting men to the
same bogus sort of corrective therapies
like the new masculinity workshops sort
of presented
new residential workshops are like
really really expensive uh workshops
that are about curing men of their
masculinity that are extraordinarily
expensive and entirely ineffective uh
they're done by this really they're just
instagramers who have done like a
six-week course on somewhere over and
that thinks they're a therapist a
therapeutic coach I think you have to
call themselves and it's basically about
correcting the problems of masculinity
it's the same thing we we subjected
women to like 50 or 60 years ago for the
so-called what's the female hysteria I
don't know the story about it so female
Hysteria
um it was basically a phenomenon that
looked at Women's distress and it
basically pathologized it as a problem
to be solved I think I mean I think it
was um part of his masturbation
therapies that were a cure and Pro or
anti pro pro yeah yeah masturbate more
and it'll get more more to merrier I'm
sure I'm sure that there are many many
women that are like yeah very very
hysterical all the time actually I feel
like I need this treatment well I can't
hurt to try
um
and you see this if you Google it you
see the same these black and white
photos of women in sort of core being
experimented on and it's it's horrific
and I feel like we pathologized female
distress instead of listening to it we
pathologized it as something that's
wrong in them and I I feel the same
about toxic masculinity I feel like the
frustrating thing is that the people
that disagree with me often don't
realize that the thing we disagree on is
semantics because I I do I believe there
is
there are problems within men there were
Violent Men there were men are just very
aggressive competitive uh that are not
great at expressing their feelings those
are the problems I agree exist are
so-called toxic masculinity but I feel
like toxic masculinity is a term takes
the problem and stuffs into men's heads
and this is your problem and if you want
to solve it only you can solve it rather
than saying it as a societal issue so I
mean I would say toxic attitudes towards
men or toxic attitudes towards
masculinity which all of society is
guilty of perpetuating including women
and um
I feel like toxic masculinity just again
confines the problem to men's heads it
sort of takes a problem and puts them
puts them in into men's heads in a
slightly opposite patriarchy where
it sort of puts men inside of the
problem so patriarchy puts men inside of
the problem toxic masculinity puts the
problem inside of men and whatever it is
it's like this is your problem and like
for um for a political movement that's
all about accountability it's like well
aren't we all accountable for what's
happening to men like what about the way
we value men or sort of dating standards
that men are held to are they not are
they not part of it there's a really
great study by a child psychologist in
Canada called Crystal Tomlinson and she
found that it was actually mothers who
were perpetuating harmful gender
stereotypes into their children men the
fathers didn't really care either way
but it was often the mother and then
so
um they did basically a
IAT test I think it is where you're
looking at different images of girls and
boys exhibiting different behaviors and
it basically measures the response of
mothers and fathers to the different
expressions of emotion so a boy crying
for example and it found that the
mothers were
um a lot more disapproving of like
things like boys crying so boys breaking
the gender stereotypes and uh
and it found that surprisingly fathers
didn't seem to have really any sort of
preference either way why do you think
that is why do you think there's a sexed
difference there
I mean it could simply be that mothers
spend more time with children
uh
I honestly don't know I don't I wouldn't
want to comment on something I'm not not
get out over your skis George let's get
some yeah let me give you one let me
give you one let me give you one from me
so there's something called the sexy sun
hypothesis and in it a little bit
already yeah it suggests basically that
what women are trying to do is find
fathers that are going to give them
attractive Sons because attractive sons
are more likely to have kids right I
think that what you see here is maybe an
inbuilt biological mechanism that women
have which is a predisposition to make
their sons attractive to Future women
and they have deep down in understanding
that the more prestigious and
domineering men on average have better
mating outcomes they're more likely like
remember what we are we are
grandchildren optimizing machines that's
what humans are we're not children
optimizing machines we are grandchildren
optimizing machines and once you get two
generations away from you away you go
crack on but I I think that that could
be that could potentially be a big part
of it I loved your breakdown when we
were talking about that conception of
left and right and and how people see it
uh one side is a Mindless cacophony of
anti-male bigotry minimization and
Erasure the other an equally Antiquated
and equally restrictive worldview of
alpha males and pickup Artistry so good
did I say so good oh yeah you did mate
you would Smith that very well yeah yeah
well I see a lot of stuff in there fan
of your own work
um but yeah I I think so one of the
things one of the things that you're
trying to do is is improve this
conversation and improve the way that
it's communicated given the fact that
you're trying to display these ideas
what have you learned about
the way that it is effective and
ineffective what is missing from the the
communication side of the conversation
when it comes to this topic
uh I just think a really
people just want to live in denial a lot
of the time that people don't don't want
to believe it doesn't matter how much
information you present to them or how
compelling an argument you make like uh
some of the studies are presented in
domestic violence especially
like we're talking about meta-analysis
of 200 surveys taken across 30 years
collected by
probably the greatest expert ever on
domestic violence the man who invent the
man who founded the field of family
violence research did the study and he
found that it's not gendered issue men
and women abuse each other more or less
equal rates Professor Murray Strauss the
late moisture he's like I don't know if
it is he literally invented the
instruments we now use to study domestic
violence and he's saying that so if I'm
given that data and I still can't change
one's mind I really don't know what hope
there is but
I have learned I've learned I mean I
still find the issues extremely
interesting but more and more I'm
finding it even more interesting how
reluctant people are to listen to what
I'm saying like especially when it's so
compelling not only not listen but not
everyone to discussed and any discussion
of it makes you a misogynist or in cell
or some sort of Virgin I don't quite
know
um I've learned that
the way I described it was um
Minds aren't changed through like cells
of a spreadsheet there's change for the
cells of a human heart
which by that I mean that it doesn't
matter how many pie charts I flick
around or how many spreadsheets or
diagrams it's very dehumanizing way of
talking about very important issues
because one single story from like
wanting a person is way more powerful
than any pie chart I I mean I don't want
going into the habit of quoting Stalin
but he said one death is a tragedy a
million is a statistic and I've really
learned the power of personal anecdotes
and that's something we can all learn
from feminism where they're saying the
personal is political and they are
framing these important political issues
as personal problems so I try creatively
I try to combine different types of
information like I'd like to see some
data I like to see some personal quotes
and stories maybe some expert testimony
I try to mix them around in different
ways and present them with different
sort of perspectives and strategies
sometimes I take the same issue remix of
another
honestly overall it's been very
difficult it's been kind of frustrating
but
at the same time it has an added benefit
because so many people are not willing
to talk about these issues it's
excellent for me as a content creator
because it means there's so many topics
that I can talk about that no one else
wants to talk about it's like
I I described it once as like eating
from the garden of forbidden fruit
where no one wants to talk about these
issues and I'm there gobbling all up
I'm like yeah this is great no one's
talking about this no one's talking
about that this is a great perspective
for no one and like no doubt my chickens
will come home to ruse eventually yeah
um
I feel it's a combination of many
different things I do feel like it's a
brand identity crisis within men and
boys but I also feel there is a
reluctance to actually give a [__] from
people like which people always talk
about why don't Mentor why do men crying
it's like oh maybe because no one cares
maybe that's why
maybe we simply don't care there was a
there is a division of Inner Space about
whether that's a biological thing or
environmental thing normally like most
things it's both
but I do feel like we seem to care more
and empathy Gap is
or male gender blindness I think John
Barry talks about when you're gamma bias
is that gamma bias yeah
John Barry two for two today yeah
sometimes you read stuff and you're just
like that is so true that we do we do
like a raised male to gamma biases how
we highlight and minimize gender
depending what we're talking about so we
highlight male privileges in an area of
privilege we highlight the male sex and
in the area of victimization we
highlight the female sex and by that I
mean like if you look at newspapers any
any of your visitors that want to go
away and do some homework look at how
the news reports social issues if
there's like 100 people killed and two
of them are women you'll be like
98 passengers killed and two including
two women and what we're doing is we're
highlighting women when they're impacted
and we're raising men when they when
they're when they are impacted like
another example I can give you is in
London where I currently live uh last
year we had the worst year in history of
knife crime in terms of the amount of
teenagers killed
um I mentioned earlier how we talk about
um gay people historically we don't talk
about gay men same for this we use the
word teenagers another team just up to
their 30 teenage 35 teenagers and then I
looked at the data
which no one's going to do apart from
some nerd like me every single one is a
boy not 90 not 95 everyone all of them
every single one was a boy or young man
mostly inner city black boys
and we were reporting in the news he was
as teenagers or children or like 15 year
old like and I was just like you should
be saying boys if it was just women if
it was just women that would be headline
news and what I know another more recent
example was a another investigation a
shocking results came out from a study
into the Metropolitan Police
and it found that they were they were
strip searching children as young as
eight so if you again Google it children
as young as they strip search by police
that would be your headline you'll find
again and again and again and then
here's me digging into their data and I
found that 95 of those children were
boys again black boys and sometimes
races brought into the title sometimes
it's like black black children but never
95 boys and it's just like we wouldn't
put up with that if it was the other way
around it was 95 girls people would lose
my mind including including who's their
mind including myself like we wouldn't
put up with that but when it happens to
men and boys we erase it another place
we highlight
um
gender is in perpetration
so obviously you have a gunman henchman
and Knife Man and con man and it's like
again a man man man I know like uh we
look at like 911 for example we very
much highlight the fact that all of the
terrorists Were Meant all of them but no
one highlights the fact that every
single firefighter and when I say every
single one I mean 100 of the
firefighters killed running into these
buildings were men I think it was like
340 something firefighters killed and I
might fire men like I get it I'm all for
firefighters but when it is all fire men
please say firemen like and that's I
feel like when we erase men from those
situations the heroism of men bravery
and sacrifice of men we also erase our
ability to construct the very Role
Models you talked about because we're
not seeing
300 men sadly lose their lives dragging
innocent Americans out building so that
is that's something that is tragic and
it makes it upsets me that
maleness masculinity is often defined by
sacrifice and the loss of life
but it is that is something that we
should all be proud of and that's
something that men can look to be like
wow those men gave their lives for
others and they are heroes from now
until forever and like I guess that
feeds into what you said about where are
the male role models and the answer is
weeds that raise masculinity we
highlight the bad bit we erased a good
bit and then I'll give you one final
example was that the year after George
um George Floyd is killed it was a a
really really shocking murder of a young
woman called Sarah everard in London
uh and it was awful by Wayne cousins who
is just human filth and again the
headlines were the same male violence
male violence male violence which is
fine we'll talk about male violence but
the following week a young man dived
into the Thames to save a woman he
didn't even know and he died he lost his
life saving a woman and there were no
headlines about male heroism male
sacrifice male bravery and we just again
highlighting the bad minimizing the good
creating a very warped one-sided
perspective of men and masculinity that
really does hurt everyone including boys
because they're growing up in society
that doesn't show the good of men and
only shows the bad and that's what leads
people back to Andrew Tate who I don't
appreciate and I feel does I don't like
him for my own personal reasons because
I think he brings a very bad brand to
the sort of area I talk about
and he's a poor role model but he's a
result of the left's failure in my
opinion he's a reflection of our
inability to talk about boys and men in
good faith in a way that isn't toxic
there's some patriarchy that in orders
of a nonsense
we're not giving boys the space the talk
in good faith or men and they're going
to other people it makes sense and if we
don't fix it it won't be agitated it'll
be someone else it'd be someone worse
potentially and um he is our failure and
our best to clean up and
um
I just wish more people would see that
but think about it this way man
being your political leaning is very
highly heritable right whether you're
from the left or from the right it is
very very highly influenced by your
genetics which means that there are
going to continue to be people from the
left and that are going to continue to
be people from the right and some people
can move between two but there are a
large cohort of people who were born to
be on the left and born to be on the
right
um is there maybe a little bit of a
gender skew one way or the other there
might be there might be a few more a a
small percent more women on the left or
maybe women on the right I don't know my
point being both cohorts have massive
massive numbers billions
of men and women inside of both of them
and if one side decides that they're
going to abandon the conversation they
are seeding ground to a side that they
don't agree with and here's the other
thing
people are more politically racist than
they are racially racist
people
um
parents of children a huge proportion
nearly 50 percent of Democrats fear
their child marrying a republican they
fear their child marrying a hate that I
hate that that's way more people than
fear their child marrying a Chinese man
or or marrying like an African lady or
something like do you know what I mean
like way more there is much more bias
against the other political party than
there is against pretty much anything
else so given given the fact that we
have this
if you are from the left if you refuse
to have this conversation with boys and
men what you're doing is condemning all
of the boys and men that are from the
left to not be able to hear any positive
role models which is why the right
dominates masculinity not just the
conversation you're boys and men but
masculinity as well because let's say
that people from one side aren't
necessarily always prepared to hear the
ideas from the other
if one side isn't speaking to them and
you can't cross the streams to be able
to understand what the other side says
you basically have maybe 50 of all men
unable to hear what another side is
talking to them about because they don't
have anyone from their own political
party that wants to engage
yeah I mean the left them all it's talk
of diversity never seems to want to talk
about diversity of ideas points of view
perspective uh it's only sort of things
like I'd say things that are kind of
arbitrary which is like race and gender
which still really don't mean that much
but
diversity of opinion is what I'm
interested in I mean I've seen I've seen
what you talked about the unwillingness
to sort of date or be romantically
involved with those of other political
opinions I know when I when I was dating
in my dating profile it was like I'm a
labor member but if you're a Tory I've
still got a date with you like I'm not
I'm not I'm not a baby yeah yeah and
I've got so many people that are just
calling me like there's all sorts of
stuff and I'm just like it's not going
to work out it's not going to work out
for us and uh
yeah I mean we all know it we're sort of
engaging very much in like a very tribal
sports team style let's defeat the other
side at any cost sort of politics where
I mean I I support Leicester City
Football Club and they've just been
relegated but I will support them for
the rest of my life no matter how badly
they do that's how sports team works but
we're doing that in politics now where
it doesn't matter how much we [__] up
we'll still support the left or the
right and we don't we don't look at it
the same amount of balance
um it is interesting as well how you
talk about voting
I always find it interesting how women
have outvoted men in America every year
for about 40 years so every year women
vote way more than men and if you look
at Power we always talk about power
dynamics and people talk about
whoever's in office has power which is
true but it was also power held by those
who put that person in office and
ultimately women can choose who goes
into office because they outnumber men
every single year every single sorry
election and I wish more men would vote
I don't think it's any women do anything
wrong like they have every right to
exercise their Democratic um vote but
it's interesting how we talk about women
as these sort of uh powerless people
when in fact they are the biggest voting
Block in America and that's why so many
policies are for them that's why you
have to buy an agenda of women and
Obama's sort of review of women's issues
and we have the White House Commission
of women and girls which don't exist for
men and boys like there's a dozen or so
15 I think States and a half commissions
for women and girls set up by
politicians none for boys there's four
offices of uh Women's Health in America
non for boys and men there's like a
National Coalition for women and girls
in education doesn't exist for men uh
but even like the Bureau of Labor has a
women's women's Bureau not for men and
it's like
if you consider the fact that thousands
and thousands of men die at work every
single year in America more men die at
work in America every year than all of
the American Military deaths in the
entire Iraq war for 20 years so all the
all the deaths from the Iraq War in
America that's how many men die every
year at work massive issue no men's
Bureau in the bureau in the Bureau of
Labor and I'm like come on like going
back to amends there's no office for
Men's Health four for women and I'm all
supportive of that I'm not saying let's
close the women's ones down and we're
saying let's make some for men like if
you look at the 10 top causes of death
in America
nine of them are dominated by men nine
men lead nine of the top ten causes of
death no office for men's health and not
only that but like men are more likely
to do men and boys are more likely to
die at every age group like every age
group from the neonatal to old age more
likely to die and not just America
either but
um across the world every in every
country men have shorter lives on
average and nothing is said and done
there is no I don't understand the
structure of male Advantage why does it
have so few commissions committees
departments offices to actually solve
these problems
so
I guess that's a criticism of the
patriarchy theory for you what do people
get wrong about the gender pay Gap I
know this is something that you've
looked at quite a lot yeah yeah yeah I
mean oh it's I mean there's so much to
say I mean I guess first of all I'd say
it's not a gap between men and women
it's a gap between mothers and fathers
and there's some really excellent I mean
I love Graphics there's a really great
graphic of like different countries and
you see men and women's salaries going
up like this together over time and then
women's comes down and men's carries and
going and it's like well what happened
there it was all going so well it's all
going so well and then suddenly and it's
like child they had a child and the
women have taken time off work to have a
child they get longer paternity
maternity leave in the UK
and um if they do go back to work they
go back part-time if at all so I'd say
it's better seen as a child penalty paid
by mothers and the solution to that
penalty is probably something to do with
equal paid parental leave for fathers so
if we can give fathers equal leave to
mothers
uh murders will be able to return to
work sooner and then return to their
sort of career journey and the pay Gap
will be closed through more parental
leave for dads and that's a really good
example of like
a approach I like to take where we look
at men's and women's issues as
symbiotically linked the problem of one
is the problem of another and on any
equation you've got to look at both
sides so I'd say one side of the problem
is to pick up the other side is
parentally for fathers and you've got to
solve them both I mean there's also a
lot of evidence where
men work longer hours Men Travel further
men or more dangerous jobs and work in
Industries where
um that's more higher paying
which is true but then I guess you've
got to deal with the discussion of like
well why are men choosing these jobs why
are women not working in engineering why
are women not working in stem and
there's so much to say about that but
it really comes down to
the individual differences in men and
women in general like do we have
different interests do we have different
behaviors and if so are they shaped by
our biology are they shaped by our
environment is it both and I mean it's
both it's surely both so
I guess the answer to what you're saying
is that men make different decisions men
behave differently they go for different
jobs they don't take equal parental
leave they
um they're just different people in
general and a lot of that has an impact
on salary there's a really good um the
biggest study ever on the pay Gap
I think was done by Harvard
and um
you basically looked at Uber drivers in
America so the big reason is the biggest
because they had so much data Uber
obviously has so much data and men and
women both try viewers in America and
they they looked at the pain and they
were like well women are getting paid
less at Uber so how does that make sense
because it's obviously all automated so
like what a great great way of studying
male or female Behavior to work out what
is in this Gap and there's three things
in the Gap the first was men drove at
different times at night so men would do
the graveyard shifts the early mornings
we're getting paid more they would want
to do that women less so the second was
that men were more likely to stick with
the platform for longer so they had more
experiences and they benefited from that
experience makes sense of any job and
the third reason which is 50 of the Gap
was that men just drive faster
let's drive a little faster guys then
you'll close that Gap
yeah I mean I guess it's I mean yeah
that shows it's not it wasn't
discrimination that's causing the pay
Gap in Uber it was just different types
of a heavy right foot different types of
behavior and I guess we could have a
discussion of what shapes that behavior
but we need to start that conversation
with it's not discrimination at least an
Uber different types of behavior and if
you factor in you know with men and
women same job same experience same
level same hours worked the pay gap's
like 99 cents to the dollar
and in fact Asian men are paid even more
than white men and Asian women and it's
like Asian privilege baby
not Asian privilege and you know I
really I I loved learning about this um
from some of your infographics and what
I love is the conception of the
difference is between asking why are
women paid less and when are women paid
less yeah yeah yeah that's the
conception right it's not about it's not
about a reason it's about a time and the
time is
motherhood the time is becoming a mother
and here's the thing man you know you've
seen this in the Scandinavian countries
this was sort of Peterson's Big Break
whatever five or six years ago when he
was talking about as you make countries
more egalitarian you see gender
differences between the Sexes increase
not shrink because you open up the uh
ability for your biological
predisposition which isn't predetermined
but it is a predisposition uh for you to
be able to go and do the things that you
want to do now the interesting thing is
I wonder if you were to say
um
a a mother and a father how much is
leaving the UK is like nine months
usually right for a month I mean it's 12
months but it's sort of splits in
government and the workplace okay so
let's say yeah let's say you're doing
that let's say you increased it and
let's say that there was
um 18 months and that had to be split
between the father and the mother
right so you have 18 months and that's
the household and you can choose to
split this however you want something
tells me that would be making the system
more egalitarian right the decision is
now completely in the hands of the
family something tells me that there is
a lot of mothers that would just go
looks like I'm getting
17 months and one week of leave like
crack on honey because it completely
fails to account for the fact that women
who are mothers a lot of the time love
being mothers for the most part that's
the reason that they chose to become
mothers that's not too loud yeah
presuming that um
presuming that women
actually enjoy the the experience of
becoming a mother which for lots and
lots of my female friends who are
writers who work in offices who are
high-powered lean in career style boss
baby women it's been the it's been the
single most transformative thing that
they've done absolutely adore it and if
I was to tell them that they had to get
themselves back to work earlier they
would feel like they've lost well part
of their life I'd say like that I'd say
the ideal choice for both fathers and
mothers is part-time parenting part-time
work that's what the data says both
parents want women want it more like
I've looked there's been some
interesting
studies where like I think it was the
New York Times They asked parents what
they wanted
do you want like part-time work
full-time work full-time parenting
and um and then I I found some
interesting
um Bureau of Labor Statistics data on
what actually happens like what is the
reality and it was like the biggest
difference between what a parent wants
and what they get was a full-time dads
so that the vast majority of dads are
working full-time but a lot of them want
to be sort of part-time parents whereas
if you look at the data for like
full-time parenting full-time motherhood
that was actually the closest that was
where the what mothers wanted and what
mothers got married at the most so he
got like working dads over here lots of
them working full-time but lots of them
wanted to be parents as well so I'm like
if I don't know why we don't see workers
not a choice either like everyone talks
about a motherhood isn't a choice and it
isn't but then dads don't get that
choice either like they have to go to
work they can't be like I'm not going to
go to work today because they do that's
how it works and um I don't know if we
talk about the sacrifices Farmers make
in that way uh we do we do talk about
mothers not enough and we can talk about
them more but I mean my dad he was a
career father and he was very successful
he spent his whole life traveling the
world going to conferences speaking at
large events like really smart guy we
never saw him he was out earning money
and my mum took a time off her career to
raise my sister and I
and as a result she's built a massive
network of friends like all her
girlfriends around the village or she I
imagine she met them when she was going
to like play school and going to
playground to pick us up
my dad has none of that now they're both
retired and he I guess he's not got that
same network of friends like my mother
my mum has and I'm like the price of his
sacrifices being paid now but the price
of my mum's sacrifice was paid at the
time now she's enjoying she's enjoying
retirement she's got all her friends
she's got like a family she's got a
great connection to me and my my sister
because we spent so much time with her
and I might I don't know if my dad has
that same
benefit because he spent his life
working working for us and he didn't
have a choice if you met my mum he would
not she he had to go to work and um
I think we should see the benefit of
both and we should uplift women to
become lovers if they want to like we
should give a woman CEO as much value
and respect as a mother like both are
like just disrespectful and just as
valuable
um and it's like we talk about a lot of
the left they they talk about how
empowering women to do whatever they
want uh women's autonomy but then it's
like the autonomy ends when it's her
decision to do something they don't like
like be a mother like what if a man
wants to be full-time full-time mum and
it's like well now she's internally
oppressed she's been conned by the
patriarchy yeah being a domestic
housewife she's a proponent of the
patriarchy of course she's brainwashed
she has to be brainwashed any woman has
a different opinion to me it has to be
brainwashed and it's like again without
in a darker sense like abusive women
like that's the decision women make too
but we we ignore that we don't accept
that level of autonomy when a woman
chooses our autonomy to be abusive or
violent we have a really hard time
seeing that and accepting that if a
woman comes a woman who wants to become
a CEO excellent we love it a woman who
wants between abuser less so and I know
I mean I'll quote Margaret Atwood to you
but she's she talked about my
fundamental position is that women are
human beings capable of both saintly and
evil evil doings and uh
I think that's true they're not perfect
they're just as flawed as men are like
they're no better not or worse and we
need to sort of see them in the full
sort of color of their beauty and good
or bad that's what autonomy is and um I
don't know if we extend that autonomy to
that breadth in motherhood or anywhere
else and then
God that is a real tangent what what
have you learned talking about
um women and how they communicate and
interact with men what have you learned
about
what
men want from the women that are in
their lives the kinds of conversations
that they wish that they could have
other things I know you ask your
audience a lot for feedback and you know
you get these stories from men talking
about what they wish that women would
know about them what they wish that
women would understand you know what
what is it that you think men want women
to know more about them whether it be in
terms of
relationships sexuality mindset mental
health career goals lifestyle goals any
of that
I felt that
for women to understand what the Mad
experience is like we need to go back to
the lockdown
of coronavirus and I was in London at
the time and it was awful but that
feeling you get when you were walking
around lockdown right in the midst of
the coronavirus was how I feel like is
to be a man where people are afraid of
you people avoid you people cross the
road that you go to a supermarket and
someone steps back that feeling of
unease and unfriendliness and fear
I even like the fact that your emotions
are masked I feel like it's such an
interesting reflection of the male
experience that feeling of unease and
fear and
same and it's just like it's frustrating
how the male and female experience
exists and opposite ends of the Spectrum
in a sense that men have so few things
nice said about them like the vast
majority of normal men
never receive a compliment and go weeks
months years about anything kind being
said about them but women have
compliments shouted at them from car
windows like in the street like like
this cat called and it's like oh like
men walk through Society just completely
ignored a lot of the time just ignored
doesn't matter
and there's benefits to that and
disadvantages but women have like a
spotlight Society burning down on their
shoulders at all times especially if
you're an attractive young woman and
they're like
whatever the differences are is not for
me to say but surely the answer is just
through talking about them
not identifying men as toxic or violin
or patriarchal but actually just
listening to what men are like we talked
about men man boxes we talked about how
we're lifting men out of the boxes of
like career provider uh status which I
think that can be harmful boxes to be in
we're taking those up take a man out of
those boxes but we're just putting them
into another set of boxes like male
privilege male violence patriarchy uh
male fidget these are just more boxes
and I just don't want to go in a box we
just want to be given the chance to live
our lives and um
any any answers
through listening basically yeah talk to
me about fragile masculinity I've seen
you bring this up a couple of times it's
a really interesting conception when you
think about that I remember that you you
use this example on one of your posts
about the Razer gold products and like
Ellen DeGeneres like yeah snide income
took the piss out of Bic making her for
her pen so yeah explain fragile
masculinity and how that's interesting
and through the lens of Ruthless
capitalism well well I I uh I lifted
that idea from an amazing blog I wrote I
read from a trans woman
and she was talking about because
obviously she's experienced both sides
of the gender divide and she was saying
how it's amazing how when we see pink
raises or Bic for her who Market to that
women we laugh at Bic we laugh at the
razor company we're like how stupid is
that like I can't believe you're trying
to find women by being pink and I laugh
too but when a like a nuts for men that
comes out that will crisp some men or
chocolate bar big chocolate bar we don't
do the same we blame men we're like oh
look at these fragile men wanting to buy
their blue Razor or their blue oh so
fragile it's like a real like um
difference in a way we approach those
two things we blame the products when it
they're gendered to women but we blame
the man when they're gendered to men and
um
I guess that's fragile masculinity and
it's like it's basically the same thing
but it's treated in two different ways
and uh
I hope people open their eyes a bit more
to that
what's the story of Nora Vincent
no no Nora Vincent was a gay woman uh
and a journalist who um really sad story
she thought her book I think the book's
called Inside Man she basically lived as
a man for I think 18 months just to sort
of understand what the male experience
is like and she didn't enjoy it she had
to stop early and she had to check
herself into psychiatric care
then actually um earlier this year she
uh ended her life sorry last year ended
her life by Suicide as because of her
Mental Health
uh I mean a lot of people are
politicizing her death as a way of being
like Oh look how hard it's to be a man
and the reason why she decided Ender
life wasn't no directly because of the
whole man thing but she just developed a
really strong sense of gender dysphoria
as a result as living as the opposite
gender wasn't necessarily because it was
a man
um so I want to make that caveat but she
came back from her experiment and she
was like as a women don't know what it's
like to be a man we don't know
um That's the basis I try to start out
when I'm trying to understand women's
issues women's experiences I don't know
what it's like to be a woman I have no
idea what it's like to be a woman like
sometimes I'm nearby attractive women
and I see how they're treated in my
society and it's horrible
but I don't think women understand my
experience any better than I understand
theirs and whatever the answer is like I
said earlier the solution
has to come from listening in good faith
like I have learned to take a seat and
listen to what women go through when it
comes to like Reproductive Rights
um
and I think it's important that I do but
so too there's a seat next to me and
women should sit in that when it's time
to talk about things like male suicide
men's mental health like there's a seat
for everybody
and a time to listen and too often like
male suicide especially is so often gay
kept by people that aren't even men and
it's like
kept
well I suppose we've got like the whole
concept of like
uh suicide is caused by toxic
masculinity which is a popular feminist
concept that originally came from the
myopoetic men's movement but it's
obviously been adopted by feminism and
that's used as a a lens a warped and
ineffective lens in my opinion to
understand male suicide again to blame
to blame men on being so toxic and if
men would talk more and surely the male
suicide rates would come down but the
problem is there's been studies on that
there's been studies on that too and
there was one study uh last year
university of Manchester looked at men
who had completed suicide and of
all the middle-aged men who had died by
Suicide 91 of them had sought help so
nine to one percent had actually been
and sought counter therapy or some sort
of healthcare provider and I think 30 of
them had sought help the week before
their suicide so it's like well you're
telling men to talk but 91 of men who
died by Suicide did talk and they still
died and um even more shocking is that
of those men who died by Suicide who had
been sort of seen by a clinician eighty
percent of them were deemed low risk or
no risk so of these people of his men
that died by Suicide 80 were seen as no
risk or low risk so yes I think it's
more likely that we're simply just
misreading male distress
because a lot of a lot of our
psychiatric interventions and the
psychological industry in general is is
often based on women's needs and women's
Behavior because it's an industry
dominated by women makes total sense
like uh we look at industries that are
dominated by men and we rightly identify
the ways in which it creates spaces for
men like environments for men like ideas
and strategies for men but we don't look
at a psychological industry which is
dominated by women it's like 85 of
clinical psychologists are women and
naturally not saying is intentionally
done but naturally that will create
ideas and approaches that are perhaps
more beneficial to women than they are
to men and maybe that will help us
better understand why suicide
interventions just don't seem to be
working on men as well as they do for
women
it's certainly worth discussing at the
very least
does that Richard Reeves bit where he
says four times more female fighter
pilots are in the U.S Air Force by
percentage than male kindergarten
teachers in the United States which just
blows my mind every time I think about
that yeah yeah and you know when you use
or when words like toxic masculinity are
used there's another Richard Reeves
thing it's the same concept as original
sin it's like there is something inside
of you which is inherently
wrong it is a part of your makeup and it
must be expunged we must come in and we
must do the exorcism you must prostrate
yourself upon the altar of gender
ideology to be able to fix this problem
and the main thing that it does like
regardless of whether you think that
there are toxic elements of masculinity
or not what it does is it causes men and
boys to check out of the conversation
yeah if I am told yeah yeah that there
is something inherently built inside of
me which is is wrong and reprehensible
and it must be cleansed it must be
sanitized and sterilized out of me guess
what I'm not [__] listening yeah yeah
I'm not going to listen to what you've
got to say to me because you evidently
have
such a a transparent veneer thin
level of care for any experience that I
go through from hearing anything that
I've got to say we're not existing on
the same plane no yeah no it is the
parallels between like patriarchy Theory
and the original sin are
very interesting to explore
um and it just lacks it doesn't have the
same depth that I think is required to
understand very complicated issues very
complicated issues you look at domestic
violence which is often seen as men's
men and acting patriarchal control over
women
although power control is certainly a
factor it's only one of about three
dozen factors many of which are more
important than power and control and by
just seeing domestic violence through
patriarchy Theory we're actually losing
a huge part of the picture another
another example
University of Cambridge University
Cambridge study looked at violent
fantasies in men so men who fantasize
about being violent often that man is
called toxic that's a toxic man but then
they looked at his experiences in
adolescence and they found that about 97
of the most bullied Boys in school went
on to have final fantasies later in life
so a huge percentage 97 the most bullied
boys violent fantasies in adulthood and
um the academics work on that paper they
hypothesized that
fantasies of violence are coping
mechanism developed by boys to deal with
violence to come so these boys are being
bullied so much that they develop this
coping mechanism of fantasizing about
violence that they never got rid of and
They Carried into adulthood and then it
became a man who fantasizes about
violence so I guess I would encourage
people to not see the man who is
fantasizing about violence and instead
see the bullied boy behind him
and suddenly you start to get a bit more
compassion for that man and you don't
even necessarily need to have compassion
you just need to understand that we can
talk about these things about justifying
it
but we do need to understand that some
of these issues are more complex than
just simple one-word catchphrases and
hashtags and the fact that we use
patriarchy Theory not just to understand
domestic violence we use it in the
standard it's loads of different issues
such as the pay Gap as you mentioned
and it's not good enough I always think
of it as like trying to explain
um complex societal issues with the same
one-word answer is like trying to fix a
really meticulous watch with a
sledgehammer it doesn't work it's not
fine enough you just see to set up
making a mess and like we now have
access to really interesting complex
economic psychological anthropological
um tools that can help us understand the
pay gap for example and we should start
using them rather than just falling back
on his Antiquated regressive very
divisive and extraordinarily vague words
uh just not good enough anymore
all right we need to have a real
academic evidence-based conversation
around these different issues that isn't
so dramatic it's so dramatic it's spooky
it's like scary these words like they're
patriarchy they're manosphere toxic
masculinity it's like it's borderline on
fairy tale sort of language and it's
like I think we are we can do better
and uh I hope I hope I've proven a
little bit of how uh we can do better
through through my page
dude I absolutely love the way that you
speak I think that it's incredibly
eloquent I think it's very very balanced
and the main thing that I want people to
take away from today you know if you're
a woman and you've been listening to
this it probably is a bit uncomfortable
because it's it's hard to hear a
struggles
the the modern framing of almost any
conversation about one group and another
is that if you are talking about the
struggles of one it is implied that the
other is somehow to blame at no point
during this conversation have we said
women
they're the problem it's them these
these [__] at no point have we said
this
um what I would really love is for more
of this conversation this is exactly the
conversation I talked previously you may
have heard me talk about a third wave
manosphere
you heard me talk about this no okay so
first word hey this is the ah sounds
really cut against Academia coming up
can't wait to hear no it's not this is
this is Cutting Edge bro signs um so
first wave you understand there was
different waves of feminism they were
fighting for different things first wave
first wave manosphere was pickup artists
it was mystery and Neil Strauss it was
the game it was negging it was Day game
and pulling and stuff like that me too
comes along that could no longer survive
there needed to be a sanitized version
of sort of men's mostly dating but kind
of also started to creep into
masculinity advice that rose up for the
second wave which was red pill it was
alphas and betas and cooks and soy boys
it was Andrew Tate it was fresh and fit
it was like that world right yeah now my
belief is that we have the opportunity
to do a third wave manosphere and the
third wave manosphere would be not
seeing women as the enemy it would be
not adversarial it would not be
antagonistic to the other sex it would
be trying to integrate the positive
elements of masculinity allowing men to
be masculine but to transcend and
include their emotions that are
difficult to be able to talk about them
but not just talk about them at a
surface level to be able to act off the
back of them and that for me is what I'm
most excited about at the moment I'm
really really excited about the
conception of a third wave manosphere or
call it what you want holistic
masculinity integrated manhood like it
doesn't matter about what we call it
right yeah I'm talking about
content creators like Hamza who I think
is a really good influence for young
boys he's telling them they need to
train more he's telling they need to
look after themselves they need to have
a good uh society and uh support group
around them people like David Buss
people like Richard Reeves people like
yourself people like John Barry with the
female psychology like all of these
people are putting forward a positive
non-adversarial positive sum not
zero-sum not negative some positive some
relationship and and way that men can
show up in the world and again for the
guys that are listening there is a trend
on the internet
for men to start to point the finger and
make these big [__] sweeping
generalizations about all women are and
all men are there are averages on
average everybody that's listening to
this is not part of the average they're
not part of the average because you're
listening to a one and a half hour
conversation about the in-depth nuances
of what masculinity means in the modern
world you don't show up or expect
average from yourself in pretty much
anywhere else in life so why start
throwing these massive broad stroke
generalizations around the accuse
another group of being the ones that are
in the wrong I don't think that I think
that we can do better I'm positive that
we can do better when it comes to this
conversation and I'm very very glad that
you George at the tin men are a part of
this you are an un as yet uh
unallied but soon future member of the
third wave manuscript well I mean I'm
happy to be a member maybe we can
consult about some sort of renaming yeah
it's The Branding problem again like
yeah yeah well that's my job like I I
love this what you said excellent I am
fully on board of that I think we need
to identify both the good and bad of
masculinity
um I mean one of the like you said like
one of the things I hate is
generalizations I often point out in the
comments a lot of people make the broad
stroke
um generalizations about feminists in my
comments and I'm just like listen like
if you're if we're asking women not to
make generalizations about men and what
right do you have to make
generalizations about feminism
um and yeah I wish we would listen a
little bit more I wish we would see
masculinity as soon that can be good or
bad I wish we saw it as something that
is in a lot of ways immutable in the
same way that sexuality is immutable
we've come to terms with the fact that
someone that's gay that is an immutable
part of who they are that's how they
were born and like why can't we look at
masculinity and feminine the same way
like sure you can change and bend your
masculinity but that's just who you are
and there's nothing wrong with that also
you need to just get over these dramatic
World Views really good book you should
read Chris it's called factfulness by
Hans rosaling I don't know if you read
it I've heard of it a million so good he
talks about he talks about overlapping
overlapping distribution and on average
also Richards talks about it and he's
just like distributions overlap and
we're talking on average like when I say
women are one way men are the other it's
not this it's like this like men and
women are overlap the distributions are
overlap and we're talking in general
terms about these different groups it's
not very sexy it doesn't fit into a
tweet unfortunately but if you're not
willing to engage in these discussions
in a more extensive manner then perhaps
you shouldn't be part of it at all it's
like it's difficult it requires
listening requires Nuance it requires
putting aside your personal differences
in many ways possible even like your own
experiences
and try and actually listen
and I better understand and um
I just think
the factfulness thing is very
interesting because it talks Hans
rosling as like a world leading was a
world-leading professor of global health
and he talks about how we have a an
overly dramatic worldview because we
only see the very worst things like a
million men and women go to work eat a
sandwich come home go to bed boring but
one of those people will get stabbed to
death on the way suddenly it's
everywhere and we were looking at that
and we're like oh my God it's so
dangerous so scary knife crime violence
but in reality it's actually not like
that if you look at Global Trends things
are getting better things are getting
safer we live in the safest time in
human history he did a thing called The
Gap minder test where he took
I think he took 12 answers yeah 12 12
questions about like vaccines education
poverty uh disaster zones like things
that people think they know a lot about
one of the questions was like what
percentage of the world is vaccinated
the answer is 80 but no one got it right
you found that of the quiz which is
multiple choice if you just guessed
every single answer of 12 you would get
um
four four of sorry it's
note 16 basically found that if you
guessed you would do better than the
people that actually took the test
because we have a systemically negative
view of the world we only see the world
that's very very worst and he said that
if I took this quiz to the zoo
and wrote the answers on bananas and
threw the bananas into the cage the
monkeys would do better on current
affairs than human beings because the
monkeys haven't been subjected to this
Preposterous dramatic
um worldview yeah I call I came up with
a meme for that two memes actually one
is self-reinforcing antagonism which is
where one group feels maligned the other
group doesn't it doesn't feel like
they're listening therefore I feel like
I'm more aligned therefore I doesn't
feel like they're listening therefore so
the gap between the understanding of
both sides the failure of cross-sex mind
reading and and the other which really
relates to what you're talking about
although I only spoke about it in the
dating space was recursive red pill
learning so recursive red pill learning
um talks about how
chat GPT is now being trained on chat
GPT data so presuming that there is an
error rate within the data it is
creating an error rate on top of an
error rate on top of an error rate and
it's going to create this recursive
problem the issue you have with a lot of
conversations on the internet generally
the most egregious stories are the ones
that rise to the top because they're the
most egregious you know if if a guy
leaves for work and comes back and finds
that his wife's cheated on him with like
three men and now he's got a gluten
intolerance and lives under a bridge and
she took him for all that he's worth
quite rightly that's going to get a
hundred thousand up votes on Reddit
because it's [__] mental but
that because most people live most of
their lives through the internet and
because the stories that get the most
attention are the most egregious stories
people who don't have any counter
actuals who see these extreme examples
believe that that's the way that the
world is and then it gets propagated by
other people who are part of that same
content machine so that's the recursive
red pill uh red pill learning side of it
but it's the same for everything you
could have recursive feminist learning
as well as soon as you retract yourself
away from the world as soon as you don't
spend all that much time day to day in
IRL around normal people most of whom
get up and go to work have a family get
a nice dog and just [__] watch
Netflix and chill out and maybe go to
the gym in the morning that's most
people right yeah I have what you see on
the internet is not thrilled it's not
real guys it's just the internet like I
noticed that one of the best things to
do when you're stressed out on the
internet just go outside for like 20
minutes like it's really not as exciting
as dramatic it's kind actually kind of
boring real life in the best possible
way
um but you're right in that in terms of
what the way we perceive reality we
either see like people winning the
lottery and quite literally or people
being killed and there's very little in
terms of narrative forming in between
that no one wants to watch a new story
about items no someone that goes to work
and does nothing and comes home it's
like what sort of headline is that
boring and I mean in in men and boys
advocacy that's called um Apex fallacy
so and that's that's what hurts men
because we see all these rich men Jeff
Bezos Bill Gates Mark Zuckerberg white
men especially it's oh look how rich
they are and they're the tiny little
Apex at the top of the pyramid but also
we forget the fact that the very bottom
of the pyramid if you look at homeless
but homeless people also
disproportionately meant like men are
overrepresented at the very bottom and
the very top and yet we only ever seem
to want to point a finger at the top
which is fair enough but again it's a
lot more nuanced than we like to pretend
and the world isn't as exciting as
dramatic or as scary as it seems and I
feel like we should go outside a little
bit more and uh remind ourselves of that
I think touch some grass George look
dude hang this one home getting the hell
out of you uh I I love the work that you
do everybody should go and check out at
the Tin Men on Instagram uh where else
should they go do you do other stuff too
uh my only thing is I'm only one person
like people keep being oh do a tick tock
do a YouTube do this do that and I'm
like I'm one person this is just a
part-time thing I've actually also got a
job so yes it is just Instagram at the
minute at the Tin Men I'm on Twitter not
that active but I've put all my effort
into Instagram I want to absolutely nail
that and then really what it is is my
Instagram is more about research and
development for what I hope one day I'll
be a documentary I want to sort of learn
about how do I have how do I navigate
these very treacherous issues issues how
do I walk this type rope that's that's
phenomenally difficult like the the
world of boys and men advocacy is often
compared to literally the alt-right
white supremacy and being a Nazi so
that's the bedfellows I'm starting out
with I'm trying to find a way of having
these discussions that hopefully
progress to the conversation and
eventually I can build into some sort of
documentary or when I've worked out what
issues work what sort of what sort of
language is effective what sort of
creative strategy is
um
most resonates most of an audience then
I'm going to sort of try and adapt that
into a documentary but that's down the
line for now it's just at the Tin Man on
Instagram and you can find me there
looking forward to a meeting you see you
in the comments there's lots of comments
so lots of debating going on like huge
long big paragraphs of text the best the
best comment I ever got made me laugh
and I still think about it some guy was
like holy [__] every comment's an essay
and I was just laughing so hard at it I
was like thank you that's such a such a
compliment like normally on Instagram
it's just like yes yes yes
okay yes Queen louder louder and then
like for me it's like big text and then
I you keep if you say something and
don't like me you wanna you wanna call
me out I'll pin I'll pin your comment
and hopefully we can have a good
discussion so
I hope it's a rich and interesting space
and if you like it can follow if you
don't like it also come follow and we'll
chat about it so yeah
I appreciate you thank you George thank
you thanks for having me on if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe